hello and welcome to the eighth video
regarding fundamental investing with the
use of rogue ramming where we left off
we were compiling this list of the
Russell 3000 companies that we got from
Russell calm and where we left off we
basically got all the names and just the
ticker right we separated that from this
PDF file and now what we want is really
just the tickers and a big long array
that looks like an array that we've been
using so the next thing that we're gonna
do is open up the script that we've been
working with and really I guess what I
would tell you to do is make a new
script and save this script because you
might you know you might want to use
this exact script and just replace this
and people I've hunted by the Russell
3000 array and then and replace that
down here but what I'm going to do is
since I'm just using this this script
for these video tutorials I'm just going
to do ctrl + delete but again if for you
you might want to open up a new one so
yeah use your own judgement there now
what we're gonna do is make a program
that's going to pull those Russell 3000
just the tickers and make an array for
us so we don't really need to import
anything and then so what I'm going to
do is make tickers an empty array and
now we're gonna do define parse parse
Russ no parameters and as always we're
you're going to a case and a try and
accept and I have exception e print
string e we won't have any other tryna
accept so I'm just gonna print the
string if it fails now what we're gonna
do is read file equals open and whatever
you title that file I called mine
Russell 3000 and also keep in mind he's
being the same directory as this script
otherwise you'll need to put the full
path or a path anyways anyway Russell
3000 dot txt what do we want to do want
to read so just an R and read that file
now the next thing we're going to do is
split file
equals read file dot split by a newline
now we're going to make a for loop to
run through each line so for each line
in split file what do we want to do well
first we should probably split up that
line now how can we split up that line
well what we want is the end group of
characters all right like this it's the
same on every line it's this little
group of characters right at the end so
what could we split by well in my
opinion the best way to split this up
would be by a space and then we want to
take the negative 1st element right so
it'll make because depending on how many
you know words are in the name of this
company it might be different like this
is 1-800 flowers com but then you've got
some that are just like this one 3m Co
which only has two words so we can't go
you know positively but we could say not
the zero element but the negative first
element so that'll take us to the last
element no matter how many elements in
that array there are so split by space
and then the negative first element so
it close out of this so split line is
going to be each line that's split by a
space now the ticker is going to equal
split line and negative one for the last
element basically in that right now what
we're going to want to do is is
reference our tickers array and we're
gonna say tickers dot a pen thicker and
then once this for loop is completely
done running through all we need to do
is just print tickers and it will give
us a printed out version of this Russell
3000 that's in the perfect format for us
to just simply do a copy and paste so
you'll see what I mean in just a second
so print tickers save that run it move
it over quick enough and in a minute
after it runs through everything it
should print it oh you know what we
didn't call the function so if you
didn't put it in your script now type
with me
Horace Russ and then hit enter
now it should give you a printed-out
array which is perfect so all we need to
do now is just highlight it all the way
to the top and copy so you've got you
know just the array part and the night
just for example you could say Russell
3000 equals and that was the whole array
so you just hit paste or copy paste
whatever just paste don't copy anything
and now you've got that array and now
you have a full array of the Russell
3000 that now we can use to hit up Yahoo
for all of these companies so now now
what I'm going to do is put this back
into our original script that we only
really ended up finding it just a tiny
handful of companies and let's see if we
can find any more companies in this rut
because now that we're adding basically
2,500 companies to look into so that's
what I'm going to do I'm not going to
run opinio while I do that but so I'm
just going to copy Russell 3000 into I
guess I guess I could show you guys what
we're gonna do now so here's like an
older version of a script that we were
using so we were just looking for
anything with a less than one price to
book and then a nonnegative less than
one PG ratio so now what we want to do
is and then they just simply print it
out the p12
the next thing that we'll do is actually
print out or require a greater than zero
less than one p12 probably in the next
video but anyway what we want to do is
take this Russell 3000 copy bring it
over to one of our old scripts paste
that Russell 3 in there wait a second
till it's done save and I want to say if
we throw that into the URL even though
these are all all caps it's not a big
deal if it is well let's just find out
real quick let me put so instead of for
each stocking use two parter areas they
pre stock in the Russell
I'll run it real quick just to confirm
this if not we'll run a quick function
to lowercase all of these tickers that's
not really a big deal so you save it but
I don't think that the Yahoo URLs are
case-sensitive so let me run it real
quick okay it looks like it's working
got a few n a's and some out of range
indexes but that's okay those were not
data that we were interested in anyways
as we can see we found MIT with a
price-to-book ratio that was decent but
it didn't meet our PG requirement but
already we found a why our who the
trailing were overpaying but the forward
PG were actually under paying which is
interesting we could look into that a
little bit and a decent price to book
another one though I just saw an R
although it's been losing money so
there's that the forward ratio is 0.23
but it's been losing money so you'd want
to look into that but anyway so yeah
that's gonna work so that's good so now
we're able to hit up Yahoo for the
entire entire Russell 3000 and probably
what I'll do is set some requirements
and then we'll get a list of companies
that meet these three requirements here
at least of a price-to-book less than
one PG less than one and then a PE 12 of
less than one and we'll see how many
stocks within that Russell 3 meet those
requirements and then we'll start doing
some more work with those and figuring
out how else we might be able to either
use programming or just a little bit of
computer knowledge to do some more
investigation into these companies so
hopefully you guys are looking forward
to that as always thank you for watching
thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time